-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning actor
and comedian you know
from his work on "Kenan"
and "Saturday Night Live."
He stars in "Bust Down," which
is streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-I'm going down to
that sperm bank
and I'm going go find
whose nut it is.
-And I'm going too --
to talk to somebody
because I'm a customer there
and I need to figure out
how to check my account balance
online.
-Please welcome to the show
Chris Redd, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Welcome to the show!
-Yeah, man, I'm here.
What's this -- This is tight.
I'm extra bald today.
-Yeah. Really good.
And you just walked
down the hall.
How's "SNL" going for you
right now?
-Oh, it's so good, man.
Zoe Kravitz is there.
-Very excited.
I'm very excited for her
to host.
-Oh, she's amazing
and she's the best.
And I got a new show coming out,
so this has been the best week
of my life.
-You've been very busy.
You've got "Kenan,"
where you costar with our friend
Kenan Thompson.
-Yeah.
-And you got "Bust Down."
Now, for those who don't know,
what does the "Bust Down"
refer to?
What does the term mean?
-Well, a bust down
in the black culture
has been a lot of things
to a lot of people depending on
where you're from.
-Okay.
-So, if you're from the South,
bust down, like, could mean like
if you got a Rollie
and you want to put
some diamonds in it,
you bust down your Rollie.
-Okay.
-In Chicago growing up, bust
down meant somebody that would
share their body with
the community...
-Okay.
-...all the time.
-In a sexual way.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
Sort of someone
who is philanthropic.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Ambitious, if you will.
-Ambitious. Sure.
What was the inspiration
for this show?
-Well, I got a -- I had
a meeting with a producer,
and he showed me this old TV
show that was terrible.
And it was, like, centered
around four friends.
And he was like, "Do you have
three other friends?"
I'm like, "I do." And so...
[ Laughter ]
I took that terrible pilot back
to my friends like,
"Hey, we should remake this."
And they were like,
"That's trash.
Why, Chris?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Well, if we
just do something together,
I think we can make it happen."
And after some convincing,
we just made several different
versions of "Bust Down."
That was like five years ago
now.
Today would be our little baby
gets to walk.
-And so this is four friends --
and a wonderful actor, Sam Jay,
as well.
-Yeah.
-Who you obviously knew
from "SNL," and other friends
that were on the writing staff.
But you're basically four
friends sharing a menial job.
And most of it takes place
in this break room
where you're just talking about
different things.
-Yeah.
-And you're being ridiculous
and it's super funny.
Was menial jobs something
that was in your past
before you were a comedian?
-Yeah, I've been a dream chaser
my whole life, so I just
dedicated my whole life
to being broke until I was 30.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So I had a lot of --
I had a lot of jobs.
I worked at McDonald's
maybe seven times.
-Okay.
-It was my first job,
and I remember I got fired
because I was stealing.
But they didn't know it
because they couldn't prove it,
so they just put me on
the toilets and I fired myself.
-Yeah.
-I was like,
"I'm not washing pee.
I'm fired!" Like, that's not how
you quit.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But then my best friend at
the time, two years later,
became a manager there,
but I had burned so many bridges
with so many jobs
I couldn't get hired.
So I would just go there
and crack jokes,
and that's kind of when I
figured out I was funny
'cause I would crack jokes
until they gave me food.
I was like, "Damn, I'm so funny
that they giving me food."
[ Laughter ]
But really, looking back,
I'm like, "I think they thought
I was homeless."
[ Laughter ]
"Let's feed this poor boy."
-Now, you did -- Obviously,
you've had a lot of success
doing, you know,
rap parodies on "SNL,"
but you actually tried to do
rap music professionally.
-100%.
I started writing raps
when I was 10 years old,
and they were not good.
-Uh-huh.
-My first rap was about
killing Barney, and --
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I didn't want to clean up
my room, and I wasn't gonna
have nobody telling me
when to clean up.
Like, chill.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's
a message 10-year-olds
would have been open to,
but their parents
probably wouldn't have
bought for them, yeah.
-At all, yeah.
But I remember, like,
going through a ton of, like,
different rap names.
At one point,
I went with John Dough,
meaning John Dough
as in "money."
But it was hard for people
to remember who I was.
[ Laughter ]
So it didn't work out that well.
-Yeah. Yeah.
It twisted in on itself.
-Yeah.
I was like, "I'm John Dough."
"Who?"
"John Dough."
"John -- Alright, man,
it's Chris."
-And you also have a
stand-up special coming out
this year, so you
really have stayed busy.
And it's called
"Why Am I Like This?"
"Why Are You Like That?"
What is it called? I'm sorry.
-It's called
"Why Am I Like This?"
And I called it that because
everyone's been asking me that
for as long as I can remember.
Like, my parents and my pastors
and my teachers
and friends, girlfriends.
But I'm on this journey just,
like, trying to figure myself
out as far as, like,
my mental health
is concerned and all that,
and I'm making jokes.
And I haven't found a funny way
to, like, tease my special,
so now it just sounds like
I'm doing a TED Talk about
some very emotional things.
But it's --
No, but it's great.
I even touch on being a rapper,
because, you know,
I took that so serious.
And I used to be like,
"Yo, this is for all the haters.
This is for the haters
that never believed in me,
never believed
I'd make it in rap."
Y'all were right as hell.
-You're right.
That almost never happens.
-Never.
-In rap songs,
no one ever gives credit to
the haters for
having been right.
-Yeah, man, 'cause some haters
are just intuitive.
-Yeah. They're not haters.
They're knowers.
-Yeah, they're knowers.
They see a weakness
and they're like,
"You're not good at that."
-Yeah. They are
constructive criticizers.
-Like, "I was trying to
help you, dawg."
-Yeah. "I like good rap.
I hated what you were doing."
Yeah.
-And I like improvising a lot,
so I'm going to improvise
on the special.
So I've been practicing that.
And one of the things
I've been doing --
It started with
Black History Month,
but I just kept it going.
I do -- I play a game called
"White person,
give me one black fact."
Yeah, see? Yeah.
Just as I said that,
I heard, like,
a bunch of buttholes tighten up.
You know what I mean?
Just like
a symphony of buttholes.
-If you stood up
right now with a microphone
and pretended to go
into the audience,
I think they'd go for the door.
-Yeah, they'd be like,
"Oh, so -- so -- so -- so --
so the show is over?"
But it's so fun, because people
always think too hard
about it when, like,
there's no rules besides
give me a black fact.
So they could really just say,
"I'm watching a black dude
do comedy right now."
-That's a fact.
-Yeah.
But, like, it's so
interesting that if you say
"black fact," people just get,
"Oh, I don't know nothing
about nothing."
You know?
One dude just yelled,
"Rosa Parks!"
Uh-huh.
What else?
"Uh, Rosa Parks!"
-That's fantastic.
It must be really fun
doing crowd work like that.
You also are an excellent
impressionist on "SNL."
-Thank you, man.
-And I feel like
it is a gift to comedy,
it's a gift to New York City.
We right now have a mayor
who loves the job...
-Oh, yeah.
-...likes putting himself
out there,
seems to have a good sense
of humor about himself.
-100%.
-And you got to impersonate
our mayor, Eric Adams,
on the show.
-Yeah, man.
It was one of my
favorite moments on the show.
-Got a photo of you here.
And it's -- I mean, you fit --
You fit the part, man.
I'll tell you that much.
-Yeah, we're both equally bald.
And, um, but it was --
it was nice
because he has the energy
of a lot of my uncles.
I have a huge family and, like,
you know, to talk like this
and do that and be like,
"Hey, I'm a fly dude.
I'm a really fly --
I'm-a get this city together,
y'all.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Like, you know,
I'm from Brooklyn kinda.
Jersey a little bit, too."
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, I -- That --
You know, when it comes
to, like, political impressions,
there's not a whole lot
of options...
-Yeah.
-...for a young Black man,
so when that dude strolled up,
I was like,
"Yeah, I got him. I got him."
-I like that he's almost saying
to all of us,
"I'm going to say three things
that make sense
and then a thing
that totally doesn't.
-Right.
-Every time I talk."
And I think
for most New Yorkers,
we're like, "I'll take 75%."
-Oh, you know what I mean?
That last thing you thought
you was gonna say?
Hold it.
Hold it for the next time.
But, I mean,
it's just so funny to me
because he just says
whatever's on his mind.
-Yeah.
-He's like, "You know,
the city is boring right now.
It's real boring.
You know, come on."
You know?
I just love that energy.
-Yeah.
-I just hope he does well.
-It is really --
It is so much fun
to have a mayor who just thinks
we're all, like, being
a little bit lame right now.
-Yeah, but he is
the coolest dude in the room.
I mean, the man wears bracelets
that I've never seen before.
-Yeah, he also --
I think this is a --
He tweeted after you did --
because I think he is --
Again, this is
the kind of mayor you want.
He wants to be impersonated
on "SNL."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And he wrote, "Chris Redd
is hilarious and looked great,
but it's not true that I haven't
been sick in 60 years,"
which was one of the jokes,
"which is why I got
vaccinated and boosted."
-Mm-hmm.
-"And all New Yorkers
should, as well."
Perfect example of a mayor
saying what you want to say,
and then there's one
crazy thing at the end.
"P.S. -- reddsaidit" --
your handle --
"P.S. -- reddsaidit,
you forgot my earring."
So that -- He was upset that you
did not get that on his thing.
-He called that out.
Out of all the things I did,
he was like,
"You didn't get my earring!"
And then I googled how many
times he's worn an earring,
and most of the times
he don't get his earring either.
[ Laughter ]
-I think that's like --
I think people say that to him
all the time.
They're like,
"You forgot your earring."
He's like, "Not just me."
-[ Laughs ] "Not just me.
He did, too."
-Hey, thanks for being here.
Have a great show this Saturday.
And congratulations
on the new show.
-Thank you.
-Chris Redd!
"Bust Down" is streaming now
on Peacock.
And "SNL" is back this week
with host Zoe Kravitz
and musical guest Rosalía.